ils sont déjà plus de 30 000 dans
l'Indre réunies à l'occasion du teknival
les autorités on attend deux fois plus
d'ici dimanche le rassemblement avait
pourtant été interdit on dénombre ce
soir plus d'une trentaine de blessés on
retrouve sur place Marion lompage
[Musique]
le son de system que vous entendez très
bien normalement derrière moi fonctionne
un festival illégal qui transforme le
paysage de la campagne berrichonne et
qui bouscule le quotidien des 110
habitants de la commune voisine depuis
hier matin on voit plein de voitures
passer sans forcément créer trop de
mécontentements faut qu'ils s'amuse tous
ces jeunes mais attention l'alcool et à
la drogue c'est surtout ça le plus grave
le système Marianne la dorade
dans le même registre avec une eau
supplémentaire on avait crapoté il y a
des centaines de festivaliers qui sont
venus dans cette image il est interdit
en sorte oui mais on va dire que
interdire de la musique interdire de
danser maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est on
peut plus danser où on veut on peut plus
siffler où on veut et dans tous les cas
je pense que ça dérangera personne étant
donné que on ramasse tous nos déchets
c'est une valeur de ces familiale c'est
collectif c'est un effort collectif dans
une ruche
on trouve des abeilles nettoyeuses ou
des abeilles chasseuses
[Musique]
des abeilles chasseuses non
elle nettoie exactement et on la
reconnaît facilement par rapport aux
autres abeilles quand on les voit c'est
ça c'est un aspirateur
37% des Français donc quasiment 4 sur 10
ne crois pas au rapport du GIEC et
notamment que la cause du réchauffement
climatique sont les activités humaines
37% des Français qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire vous avez une expression vous
parlez des négationnistes de
l'environnement dans notre livre
sioniste et des climatos négationnistes
ça m'inspire que on confond des opinions
avec des faits scientifiques
ce que nous dit le monde le monde nous
dit que que le monde est abusé que nous
détruisons la capacité de la nature de
nous servir à la nature nous sert tous
les jours avec de l'air propre avec de
l'eau propre avec des insectes
pollinisent
enfants de la science ça a été une palme
d'or en plus le monde du silence de de
Cousteau
émerveillement à l'époque
présenté comme une ode à l'océan et vous
vous écrivez en fait non
de l'époque en fait c'est une note à la
connerie pourquoi c'est pas moi qui ai
utilisé de merde
ce décalage est dû au lobby de
l'industrie du barbecue tire donc un
mois d'été supplémentaire représente une
hausse de 200 millions de dollars de
vente sous la pression des chambres de
commerce et des supermarchés le Congrès
a décidé d'avancer l'heure d'été de
trois semaines depuis juin dernier la
sécheresse règne sur les
Pyrénées-Orientales les services de
l'État ont enregistré un déficit de
pluviométrie exceptionnel de moins 60 à
65% du jamais vu depuis 1959 selon Météo
France
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire que dans le film on voit
qu'ils sont capables de faire exploser
un récif de corail à la dynamique pour
voir ce que ça donne et combien il y a
de poissons qui sont morts qui remontant
surface ils sont capables de chevaucher
des tortues
sur le dos d'une tortue de massacrer des
requins en disant mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces sales bêtes enfin c'est
assez phénoménal avec le recul qu'on a
aujourd'hui on se dit c'est pas pensable
les menaces physiques contre Magalie
sont devenus au fil des mois très
explicites menaces de mort de viol sur
elle et sa famille en sept mois elle a
reçu plus de 100 000 messages
malveillants qu'à penser récemment
Nabilla après avoir réalisé un test de
QI
soit qu'elle avait deux cerveaux
soit l'autre
je dirais l'autre chose qu'elle a dit
non ok je suis pas là pour mettre du
couteau sur le feu quand il était fâché
du couteau dans la braise du oui du
fioul dans le feu ouais je vois ce que
tu veux dire du charbon dans le gaz bref
avant je voulais me faire plaisir bah je
m'achetais un sac à main j'allais faire
du shopping et je m'acheter des
vêtements voilà ça fait 7 mois que je
fais plus de shopping je préfère
dépenser mon argent ouais dans de la
sécurité parce que c'est prioritaire
pour moi la sécurité de ma famille
plutôt que de m'acheter des sacs à main
et des vêtements après avoir réalisé un
test de QI peut-être qu'elle celle-ci à
penser à
racheter du shampoing
les auteurs ne nous mettons pas mal avec
cette sublissime personne c'est super en
vrai le test de culture générale la Miss
France c'est hyper stressant
c'est pas si mal je sais que vous êtes
arrivé 4e au concours de culture
générale donc pardon
vous êtes originaire de Lille qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de Ch'tis en vous Aymeric
ma sœur
[Rires]
elle a obtenu la note de 98 donc elle a
imaginé alors en obtenant cette note
qu'elle avait deux cerveaux mais pour
info une note de 98 c'est juste la
moyenne en fait ça correspond à la note
de la moitié de la population
tout le temps
le jeune que nous allons voir entre ça
et 8 ans voilà
après je me suis calé
[Applaudissements]
le 7
elle ne fait pas dans la dentelle
[Musique]
lourdeur
la lourdeur oui et c'est moi
tranquille aidez-moi enchaîner aussi
enchaînés
il y a des gens qui passent leur journée
sans rire des gens qui sont gris du coup
des gens qui sont voutés du nourrir et
hors de question que je sois comme ça
c'est horrible enfin on a qu'une seule
vie donc faut avoir ri au moins je me
dirige j'ai pas perdu ma journée